foreign  [Music]  ER how about you I started the whole  damn thing  [Music]  we decided that you could have one gift  early  what is it that is a direct hotline of  Santa Claus himself  all right revelers  welcome to your worst Christmas ever  let's go  you have 300 million dollars in your  personal vault  what I want for Christmas  [Music]  I don't want any trouble okay someone's  gonna scooch up that chimney  [Music]  not your typical Mall Santa  [Music]  are you there  [Music]  he said you were very busy tonight  [Music]  are you gonna help us  no my nice list  Santa Claus is Coming to Town  time for some for some Seasons be  who the hell are you  Boss what if he really is the real no  such thing as Santa  she's Batman  they're on my nylick naughty  that's naughty  and what do you do to the naughty ones I  give my life a call  where is this  I believe in you Santa  come on  which one of you did that Prancer  so unprofessional